T est en prison comment il a fait pour
dérange personne qui joue c'est une
somme qu'il a gagné en jouant avec son
portable dans sa celluleélé donc
légalement on on on peut pas dire ouais
mais il a gagné cet argent alors que il
avait pas le droit d'avoir portable et
enfin il y a pas de litige à ce niveau
non il n' pas le droit d'avoir un
téléphone mais il a gagné la j'ai pas vu
de litige absolument extraordina quel
moment il est en cellule et il dit j'ai
gagné 800000 il peut il peut pas se
taire ça va moi jeura fait pareil que
lui jeauris non non non non non mais
c'est c'est en sortant
ilocher de sonagne
qu Mo 8 je m'apoche plus 800000 Mo JEE
les ché est-ce que vous avez déjà gagné
une grosse somme vous comme ça au jeu cy
j'ai gagné 89 € au
loto autant dire que voilà j' d en jouer
deux fois plus oui au courses moi j au
tierc ah je croyais au marché j'ai gagné
de aubergines plusieurs milliers d'euros
ouis ah ouais ou et alors il sont où B
je lesi reperdus après continuant à
jouer parce que c'est le piège vous
jouez pu oui sarrêter ah là là là là bon
les chéris samedi soir sur TF1 c'était
le deuxième prime de la Star Academy je
tiens à dire quand même que l'équipe de
France va très bien marcher samedi soir
parce que je reçois de nombreux message
de mes amis de l'équipe de France ça va
très bien marcher vous inquiétez pas
parce que voilà à cause de toi il me
disent ouais marcher tout est de ma
faute tout est de ta faute donc je te le
dis voilà oui vous allez bien marcher
samedi soir vous pouviez arrêter de
m'envoyer des messages
d'insulte voilà ça va pas le faire voilà
Nico ça avait l'air de péter la forme en
tout cas sur la starac il était bien
tellement forme que j'adore il était
comme ça il était en rou libre NIOS
regardez gr malade vous l'avez et c'est
la star c'est le Sami soir passer une
bonne soirée regarde petitte dans à tout
de suite star mix le Star mix avec vos
noms improbables les gars arrêtez si
vous avez une petite place pour je
connais un chanteur danseur pas mal
aussi bon il est pas de la première
pluie mais pour comprendre la jeèse de
ce projet inconcevable il y a encore
quelques temps voici quelques images qui
nous n en disent un peu plus sur la
naissance de ce groupe déjà mythique oui
oui j'ai pété les PL ok
ça qu'est-ce qui se passe je vous
sens voilà ouais non mais vous êtes dur
vous arrêtez moi au moins au moins il
tente des choses c'est pas comme les
autres Mo j'aime bien moi aussi il tente
des trucs quas sa
carrière pas la gueule aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que tu as dit quandas sa
carrière carrière tu pourras reparler
l'olenceavais la carrière de je ser non
c'est vra une carrière magif toujours en
direct quasiment toujours en
direct en direct vendredi pas en direct
samedi
non comm direct lui qui je pas être en
direct les Ch vousz vu Jennifer qui a
oublié les paroles euh dans le duo voilà
samedi soir vendredi samedi soir je sais
pas je sais pas de qui même pas qui je
parle c'est vrai je les aime bien mais
je connais je sais pas qui sont ces gens
regardez non mais franchement
[Musique]
regardez j'étais à peu près je suis
exactement la femme que
j'espérais pour toi j'ai
soulevé
[Musique]
ch allongé aprè une cascade c'est
difficile comment on fait pour le
souffle par
exemple
d'Illes alors globalement les élèves ont
été bon il y en a un qui s'est détaché
c'est Pierre il a
chanté la je sais pas de qui je parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde il a été
fantastique parfois il chantait même
mieux que
moi incroyable
vraiment bon tout le monde a reconnu que
c'était Ron avec une
perruque c'est bon pas à moi c'estoun
les gars c'est bon on me l'a fait pas c
j'ai tout de suite capté le bail voilà
donc le premier éliminé apparemment
c'est margaot qui a été sauvé par le
public et en fait c'est c'est pas qui
étaé éliminé en fait c'est la pauvre
Lennie é éliminé non
c'estis Quié éliminé voilà ché Jen du
coup il a été sauvé par ses camarades
merci merci je vois qu'il y en a qui
font bien chier le samedi soir merci je
voulais que je vous montre un truc il y
a une fontaine qui a coûté 1,8 million
d' montrer ça en Autriche regardez et en
fait le style est est très chelou vous
vouz montrer ça c'est vrai 1,8 million
d'euros regardez cette fontaine
[Musique]
regardez
en terme en terme d'information si vous
nous rejoignez à 19h59 ça s'appelle la
contreprogrammation et c'est vrai que
franchement voilà non mais c'est
horrible combien ça a coûté 1,8 million
d'Uros cette merdeit en fait c'est un
collectif qui a remporté l'appel d'offre
ah ouais l'idée était de de montrer la
responsabilité de la société vis-à-vis
de l'eau dont la protection devient de
plus en plus saute aux
yeux du foutage de gueule c'est des
enfants qui ont fait ça non je sais pas
mais en tout cas c'est dégueulass ah je
vis vous montrer cette la dinguerie du
jour à 2 ans d'interval il y a une
habitante des Hautes Pyrénées elle a
rejoué deux fois la même grille de K et
elle a gagné deux fois 800000 € elle a
gagné 1,6 million d'euros en 2 ans
regardez regarde la vidéo de la MEF elle
habite Barbasan desbas 3000 habitants et
en 2021 elle se rend dans son magasin
proxy et décide de jouer au keno elle
remporte le gain avec l'option gagnant à
vie c'està-dire qu'elle a 40000 € par an
mais toute sa vie le 2 septembre dernier
cette même joueuse elle rejoue donc ses
numéros féties vous l'avez compris et là
le scénario se répète la voilà avec
1600000 € en poche c'est incroyable ce
que T arrivé à cette DME quand
mêmeis pas mal génial ça se trouve c'est
les mêmes numéros tu sais tous les 6
mois et un truc de fou si vous gagnez
vous le dites bien sûr non mais frérot
pour quoi non parce que moi je le dis
pas par exemple VO oui moi non plus he
je le dis non mais je vous donnerai un
petit quelque chose moi si je gagne ah
merci ah bah bien sûr tu gagnes 1lion 6
tu nous donnes un petit quelque chose
bien sûr ah bon bah oui combien et quoi
par exempleou c'est quoi pas on va va
dîner ensemble faites pas
chier donc là là ça veut dire que vous
n'avez pas encore 1lion 6 Kelly elle a
plus de les pas d'ailleurs je les ai pas
je je ne les ai pas mais si je les avais
je vous
Donel donc vous nous promettez que quand
vous avez un million 6 sur votre compte
vous nous
[Applaudissements]
faites on rappelle que l'insolence comm
l'sol considre comme de l'sol ser pasain
sera pas là demain pas payé
pay pas pay jeis remercier C f d'avoir
été avec nous
et c'est on te retrouve samedi 18 et 25
novemb 100 % logique et dans tous les
rendez-vous sur FR et Z0
fa c'est bon parce que on est on part on
va enchaîner là on on est à l'émission
On continue gar merci c merci merci
t'inquiète